Democrats have blasted the
administration for temporarily
separating illegal immigrant families at
the border unimaginably they have ripped
children away from their parents it is
inhumane it is cruel when you take
children away and separate families you
are doing the complete opposite of the
values of this nation those children
should be with their moms and their dads
does the president think of children as
accessories and not central to a purpose
of family sanctity in our country okay
the left says it's deeply opposed to
splitting up family so were they even
more horrified watching an American
citizen permanently separated from her
family by an illegal alien on CNN
senator Elizabeth Warren provided a very
clear answer no real problems she said
is family separations of illegal aliens
watch I'm so sorry for the family here
and I know this is hard not only for the
family but for the people in her
community the people throughout Iowa but
one of the things we have to remember is
we need an immigration system that is
effective that focuses on where real
problems are where real problems are
Marion Mendoza is the mother of police
sergeant Brandon Mendoza who was killed
by an illegal immigrant she joins us
tonight miss Mendoza thank you very much
for joining us thank you so when you
hear a politician say yeah someone died
in that said but the real problem is how
we treat people trying to sneak into our
country illegally what's your response
to that I was disgusted by senator
Elizabeth Warren here in her speak today
and what I need what I want to say to
her is stop lying to the American people
because you don't care what is happening
to the victims of illegal alien crime
because if you did you would be standing
up for us and you would be doing
something about it
we have pleaded with these politicians
to do something to protect American
citizens and they are ramping up their
protection of illegal alien criminals
and I just want to say you know there
there are so many victims Tucker and
when you think of Courtney hacking in
Texas and her husband and two children
were
killed and the illegal alien got 2 years
when you think of Sanders Cohan and
Carlos Wolfman Maryland who were killed
on the side of the road and Maryland
charged that illegal a hundred and forty
dollars for each of the men he killed
and that's the only punishment he got is
this what an American life is worth to
our politicians and to our to our fellow
Americans who don't understand this
disgusting narrative that is happening
in our country and this has become
political because it's a very
politicians who are elected into office
who are not doing a dang thing about
this and they're ignoring the American
people crying for help and they're
stepping over dead American bodies in
their rush to protect illegal alien
criminals I don't think you're
overstating that I agree with everything
you said and I'm really sad about it and
I'm sad that you've felt the sting of
these insane policies miriam mendoza
thank you very much for joining us i
want to just say that my heart goes out
to the Tibbets family and god bless them
and i know what they're experiencing
tonight and I'm heartbroken it's
unimaginable thank you very much thank
you